[Music]
Silvio Berlusconi was above all a
fighter he
was a man who was never
afraid to defend his convictions and it
was exactly that courage
that determination that made him one of the
most influential men in the history
of Italy
that allowed him to impress true
own breakthroughs in the world of
communication politics in the world
of business with him Italy
learned that it should never have limits imposed you
learned that it should never give
up with him we fought
in many battles and won for
him too  we will bring home the goals that
we set ourselves together Goodbye Yes but it's
true he
seemed mortal to me However I'm
sorry even if I
clearly think differently he is a figure
who has done something historic
in all these years and then I have a great
entrepreneur beyond politics but
taken by surprise By now he was his
age he had become a completely
residual figure let's say of the politics
of society
but in short he
remains a part
of our history here But look as far
as I'm concerned it's a
negative element of political life  so I
mean I don't know what harm it can
leave, I think perhaps Forza Italia
will find itself very destabilized